the senior lead NBA insider for the
athletic he is shams sure are Nia and
yeah he joins us now
shams how are you I'm good I appreciate
you having me on well we just brought up
the most surprising sports story of the
year
not in NBA is Derrick Rose drop in 50
what do you think it's a great timing
last year yesterday we dropped feature
on him from my conversation with him
about a week and a half ago I mean is
just tremendous and I think a lot of
people on the league respect Derrick
Rose from the upper echelon players I
talked to Kyrie Irving and Kevin Durant
and the first thing they said when I
brought up man we love them you know
special player one of a kind forever
he's been through so much multiple knee
injuries starting with the ACL in 2012
and then he had torn meniscus surgeries
over and over and over
up until 2016 and then you know he's
been relatively healthy over the last
two years he dealt with bone spurs last
year you told me I couldn't even run and
I left the team to try to figure out
what was really wrong with my body and
everyone was saying I want to retire I
think it's just an inspirational story I
think all the you know all the reaction
has been pretty spot-on it's a story of
perseverance someone that you know even
even Derek told me about it week and a
half ago like I could have stepped away
from the game how the daughter I have a
son but the game has a hold on me I want
to keep playing and you're going against
Utah which has been a pretty good
defensive team which made it even more
interesting but you know Jimmy Butler
doesn't sit out Derrick Rose is not
going for 50 so let's get to that
strategy here with Jimmy Butler is this
enough to get him out of Minnesota I
haven't gotten that says you know listen
he wanted to to see if he play yesterday
Wednesday and he contemplated sitting
out this is this was kind of
predetermined he contemplated sitting
out over the last two days and came up
with the decision Wednesday morning and
formed coach Tom Thibodeau I'm gonna you
know rest I'm gonna sit out and this is
people around the organization believe
that this is another sign another way
other tactic that Jimmy is gonna implore
to see
Minnesota and taunted old buds on moving
in I think most of all illegally that
Tom Thibodeau has been open to engaging
in conversations but their price has
been sky-high they came so close to
moving him to Miami for package Ron
young promising two-way player Josh
Richardson and that didn't pan out even
after they exchanged medical coders the
Tim rules didn't trade them after
exchanging medicals of the team you know
there's definitely a long way to go
before they actually get a deal then I
haven't gotten a sense that there's one
close but there's no question this is
him you know trying to for you use
another tactic to see how Minnesota and
the Tim will respond how desperate is
Houston to get him considering their 1
in 5 start I think they're very
desperate to get town in there they let
to incredibly vital parts of their team
go and Trevor Ariza with Bob bootay over
the summer I think people are glossing
over the fact that Trevor played 3035
minutes a night look by muta a played 20
25 minutes a night off the bench playing
multiple positions these are versatile
players you need in your lineup and they
pretty much went unaccounted for over
the summer they signed James Ennis to a
minimum contract and he's been great for
his role and the money that they're
paying him but he's not rubbery they
he's not looked Bob Luce so I think
they're reeling I think they're
desperately looking for talent I think
there's a lot of pressure around that
organization and you know they've made
their bid but let's say Minnesota is not
taking brain and Knight who's injured
marques Chris who's not even in
Houston's rotation and not really of
interest in Minnesota and four
first-round picks that you know probably
conveying the 20s over the next five six
seven years so they really don't said
they're for Minnesota to do that so
unless Houston is coming up and offering
Eric Gordon and PJ Tucker I don't I
don't think a deal is gonna happen on
that front yeah and then you know I
wonder about this with the Lakers that
yeah they squeezed by Dallas last night
but I wonder if there's that point in
the season where they make a move I said
I wouldn't make a move I would just
whatever the season however it plays out
it plays out and then reassess hit the
you know reset button but can you see a
scenario where the Lakers make a move by
trading one of these younger players
I think that's always in play you know I
would agree with what you said I think
that is their strategy in the Lakers and
not seeing how this young group this
young core continues to mess with my
bran James until you know what you have
you can't make any rash decisions it
could be very much like the Cavaliers of
last year where you see where the team
stands are on trade deadline and then
you move a bunch of guys and you make
the decisions you see fit
I don't think that type of clock is on
this Lakers team I think LeBron James
knew what kind of rebuild not a rebuild
but what kind of team use walking into
it there wasn't it's going to be a quick
fix I think you've been understanding
about the biggest thing for the Lakers I
feel in this young group is continuing
to adapt find their own way and really
understand what's a great shot on a on a
position profession by possession basis
I think you know from Kyle Cruz Alonzo
ball Brandon Ingram is just you know
LeBron James has different standards
there the game is played a little
differently when he's on your team so
they've just got a adapt and I think you
know it's a process more likely to not
make the playoffs based off what you've
seen rockets or thunder that stuff I
mean if things hold up like this I leave
Houston but I think both make it you
know you know that's that predictions
move but right now I think Oklahoma City
they just got Russell let's go back a
couple games into the season they're
looking like they're finding their way
that was a big comeback when the other
night for them so I think they're gonna
be fine but Houston has a little bit
more to worry about in terms of house in
terms of not having the the bodies right
now in the lineup with Anthony Davis
signing with LeBron James management
team does does that you know is there
like follow the breadcrumbs here and
what that means or is that just he's
going to the right people to represent
him or you know he needed to change you
know management or representation yeah
from what I was told that you needed a
change he wanted to go in a different
direction listen he can sign a five-year
230 240 million dollar super maximum
contract extension that I feel a lot of
people are starting to gloss over
and just predicting his own Lakers and a
ministry it's a great storyline right
but he has shown his loyalty to New
Orleans but there's no question at the
end of the day he wants to win this
season means a lot in New Orleans if
this team can make a run in the playoffs
I think it's gonna be very hard-pressed
for Anthony Davis to find a better
situation for him but you know he wants
to win and depending on how the season
goes he could pass on that to four max
but I think he's very still very much
open minded and loyal to New Orleans and
then we'll see his options at the end of
the season he's the lead NBA insider for
the athletic Schams
saranya joining us Dan Patrick show why
is scoring up so far it's a great
question I think what the NBA you know
with increasing the amount of fouls and
paint touches down low I think on cuts
in the low post is just continuing that
you know the hand check rule out on the
perimeter because they're bringing it on
the interior bring it more inside and
when you you you can't touch people on
the outside and then you're bringing
that same rule or applying the same
principles in the paint it makes it very
difficult right for contact it to take
place for physicality and I think you're
seeing that around the league when I
talk to players a lot softer executives
I think that rule that they instituted
before the season that emphasis point it
wasn't really a rule of an emphasis
point that the league made clear to
teams and players you know what when
someone's cutting you can't throw two
hands in to him and just a low post
contact that's increasing amount of
files in that and with the amount of
three-pointers being shot nowadays I
think everything is just skyrocketing
yeah but you're you're seeing teams get
over a hundred and forty now I'm old
enough to remember you know in the in
the 70s when teams were scoring 120 125
a night
ABA where there was plenty of scoring as
well it just we didn't really have a
dramatic rule change like we've had in
the NFL with you know but the defense
can't do any more with receivers or
quarterbacks but I just didn't know if
there was something that was that
specific where all of a sudden we see a
spike in scoring that we haven't seen in
a long
time yeah when you combine the the note
you know when you when you eliminate
contract and lemonade physicality and
you have the amount of three-pointers
that are being shot and a lot of that
has to do with what Golden State has
done over five years or so and you have
teams shooting 30 35 40 three-pointers a
night regularly and you have the amount
of bombs being called on a nightly basis
and I agree like the scoring the first
week of the season you were seeing in
the 130s and the 120 I do think that in
the grand scheme of things I think fans
enjoy it I think fans like watching
these high scoring games of course if
you're a basketball purist you probably
like you know we missed the days where
San Antonio in Detroit we're getting out
you know in the 70s and getting wins
that way you know that Spurs Cavs series
looks like it was you know distant
memory at this point but yeah the game
has evolved a greatly Schams good to
talk to you keep stirring it up we
appreciate your time as always Dan I
appreciate you thank you Matt nuts
shamsher Anya he's the senior lead NBA
insider for the athletic and stadium for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]